- [Kelly Clarkson] I'm
gonna hit this button and -
it's never too early, it's
five o'clock somewhere -
and a scenario will appear
on the screen over here.
Then, much like the drinking
game, Never Have I Ever,
Dame Helen, Adam, and I
will drink some green beer
if we have done the thing.
- [Helen Mirren] So
without saying anything,
we just take a sip?
- [Clarkson] You take a sip?
No, I'm gonna totally ask you.
(audience laughs)
- [Adam Brody] We take a sip
if we have done the thing
or haven't?
- [Clarkson] Yes.
- [Brody] If we have. All right.
- [Clarkson] Yes. So then
we'll explain ourselves.
That's what we're gonna
do after we take a sip.
So here's the first one. Here we go.
(machine dings)
- [Clarkson] Okay. Oh gosh.
What? Are you serious?
- [Brody] No, no?
(audience cheers)
- I might have done it but I'm
not going to tell the story.
He has to.
- [Clarkson] I've - multiple times.
- She's not playing.
- [Clarkson] I'm like,
I'm like multiple times.
I love being naked. Naked is fun!
(audience cheers)
- [Brody] Can I ask?
- [Clarkson] It's never not funny.
And then the older you get,
gravity makes it even funnier.
- Can I ask a technical question?
Is skinny dipping - does
it have to be in public
or can it be a pool?
- [Clarkson] No, just skinny dipping!
- [Brody] Okay.
- [Clarkson] Yeah. Naked.
- [Mirren] Oh, in that case.
- [Clarkson] Okay, okay!
(audience cheers)
- [Clarkson] He's like,
how do I get her to drink?